[Music]
on the same day as the attack on Pearl
Harbor Japan carried out a combined
attack against Hong Kong the Philippines
Thailand and Malaysia that day was
December the 7th 1941 after taking
control of Hong Kong the Japanese army
imprisoned the colony's administrators
and many British and American citizens
in prison camps and they replaced the
Hong Kong dollar with the military yen
and confiscated all of the city's
manufacturing and commercial facilities
during the four years of Japanese
occupation Hong Kong's economy plummeted
so low that it was virtually ruins and
the population it was reduced by half
but finally on August the 15th 1945
after the harsh Pacific War the Second
World War
it ended Japan surrendered and Hong Kong
it was returned to the British
from that moment on a new story began it
was time for an economic takeoff there
was a process that would transform this
city into one of the freest and richest
territories in all of Asia and indeed
the entire planet
[Applause]
[Music]
with seven and a half million
inhabitants and more than 1,200
skyscrapers Hong Kong has been the great
benchmark of almost the entire Asian
continent for the past couple of decades
however this is changing
[Music]
you see located in the middle of the
Pearl River Delta
China's great technological and
industrial area is the city of Shenzhen
in 2018 Hong Kong saw its neighbor
Shenzhen known as the Chinese Silicon
Valley snatch first place as the city
with the largest economy in southern
China that's right Hong Kong is no
longer the biggest economy over the
cities that make up the Pearl River
Delta but this has a small caveat
Shenzhen has over 10 million inhabitants
which is 3 to 5 million more than Hong
Kong so in terms of wealth per capita
Hong Kong is still much richer but
that's beside the point because what
this shows us is that things are
changing and Hong Kong is falling behind
and that doesn't mean to say that the
city's economy isn't growing it's just
that Hong Kong's neighbors are growing
at a faster rate that and the fact that
while its neighbors particularly
Shenzhen have become important
technological industrial centres from
which multinationals as influential as
Tencent DJI or Huawei of emerged Hong
Kong is only significant as a financial
center and nothing more and the question
that more and more people are asking
themselves today is well is this a sign
of Hong Kong's decline or a sign of its
rebirth yep you heard that correctly it
is sort of a black and white situation
so listen up
the city of contrasts folks is my turn
to ask you a question are you ready
which city do you think has the most
ultra rich people living in it the city
with the highest number of people with
assets worth 30 million dollars or more
I'm guessing many of you thought of New
York London or maybe Dubai right well
cold cold and freezing New York eclipsed
as city with most extremely wealthy
people Hong Kong is now home to more
extremely rich people than any other
city in the world yep Hong Kong Hong
Kong is the city with the most
billionaires on the planet right now
more than 10,000 residents in this city
of a portfolio worth more than 30
million dollars how about that so many
of you might be thinking well if the
city is growing at around 3 percent per
year and it's the cities with the most
billionaires in the world then and
things are gonna be going pretty well
right well yeah
but also no folks
Hong Kong is a bit of a paradigm see on
the one hands we have an apparently
thriving and prosperous City a modern
and influential financial center to give
you an idea Hong Kong stock exchange is
absolutely huge it lists more than 2,300
companies with a total market value of
just over four point one trillion
dollars however at the same time this
city has a lot of problems the poorest
residents are earning progressively less
and less money infant mortality rates
are rising the population is aging
rapidly and a huge percentage of the
population lives in housing that falls
well short of building standards in any
developed country in many cases these
are tiny spaces that don't even have
windows or ventilation these could truly
be described as holes folks the most
plus truffaut Bukh living spaces in the
world can be found in this city and this
is a lot to do with the fact that what
should be a well-off middle-class really
isn't nearly half of Hong Kong flats
rent for two thousand five hundred and
fifty dollars u.s. a month 70% of median
household income according to research
company demo graffia housing prices are
twenty point nine times higher than the
average household annual income in Hong
Kong
compared with three point nine times in
the US and four point three times in
Canada Takeshi ki Hara Nikkei a Asian
Review staff writer
[Music]
the folks we already talked about Hong
Kong's housing situation in a previous
video which I'm going to link to in the
description and before you jump the gun
I can already tell you that this has
nothing to do with capitalism gone wild
or corporate greed or overpopulation or
anything like that in this case it's
actually the government series to blame
because in Hong Kong the vast majority
of the lands and a good part of the
houses they belong to the government
they're all public but don't think that
that's the end of it this much much more
in October of 2018 the investment bank
Nomura
presented a report warning that they'd
likelihood that Hong Kong may suffer a
financial crisis in the coming years has
soared Hong Kong sits in the danger zone
for a fresh financial crisis one of the
main reasons for this is that a good
part of the population has taken huge
loans to buy a home therefore a very
high percentage of Hong Kong residents
particularly young professionals they're
up to their necks in mortgage debt Hong
Kong has very large credit and property
market overhangs since 2008 real
property prices have risen 125 percent
and the ratio of private non-financial
credit to GDP has surged to 299 percent
and if we add the fact that wages
haven't increased and the economy
depends greatly on China whose own
growth seems to be slowing down this
could be a recipe for disaster
[Music]
I want to leave because Hong Kong is no
longer what it used to be my plan is to
get a masters degree in Canada find a
job and start a new life
Jonathan Chan a 24-year old Hong Kong
student because of course killing
yourself working endless days to live in
a tiny house which you have to pay a
huge mortgage leaves you very little
disposable income doesn't really make
you feel very optimistic at all and then
on top of that you can't set up anything
on your own because commercial space is
also incredibly expensive which makes
matters even worse well that's precisely
what more and more young Hong Kong
people are thinking check this out
[Music]
according to a 2018 survey by Chinese
University of Hong Kong 51% of people
between the ages of 18 and 30 said that
they are thinking about leaving the
territory Takeshi Kihara Nikkei staff
writer more than half of the young
population want to live somewhere else
and that's incredibly worrisome and then
we need to take into account China's
increasing political interference and
the growing restrictions on political
freedoms Hong Kong bans pro-independence
party is China tightens grip Hong Kong
national party banned in the interests
of quote national safety Hong Kong press
freedom in question as ft journalist
denied visa as you can see it wouldn't
be unreasonable to say that we're facing
something like the decline of Hong
Kong's splendour the city folks which
dazzled the world by becoming a
financial commercial and cultural center
[Applause]
for decades Hong Kong had the third
largest film industry in the world an
industry that was thought to even rival
Hollywood itself but hang on a second
because some argue that yeah all of this
has happened but now the city is about
to experience a rebirth so now the
question becomes the Hong Kong's best
days actually ahead of it
[Music]
the new Chinese Hong Kong we've told you
here on visual politic that the Chinese
president doesn't really like this whole
one country two systems' thing Xi
Jinping is determined to reduce Hong
Kong's political autonomy well to
achieve this he has presented a great
plan
the Great Bay metropolitan area project
you see the Chinese president wants to
turn the entire Pearl River Delta where
cities such as Hong Kong Macau Shenzhen
or crime Jo are located into a large
metropolitan area that is perfectly
interconnected and has immense economic
integration as we're talking about more
than 70 million people in a GDP that in
2030 according to morgan stanley will be
over three trillion dollars that's
larger than the economy of the entire UK
so far the big infrastructure projects
are already a reality a high-speed train
has already been inaugurated between
Hong Kong Shenzhen and Guangzhou and
also the longest bridge in the world now
connects Hong Kong and Macau this by the
way is a connection that is 55
kilometers long which understandably
cost an absolute fortune
the three regions including Hong Kong
and Guangdong Macau the problem the
Chinese government wants all this
integration to end Hong Kong's autonomy
and among other things although they are
formally a single country regulations
laws and courts the different in Hong
Kong than they are in mainland China
there are even borders and customs
between the two territories
so in order to make the metropolitan
area really work some harmonization
would have to take place which of course
means that Hong Kong would become
increasingly Chinese since that when its
autonomy agreement expires in 2047 it
wouldn't be renewed without strict
conditions needing to see all the pieces
now well there's still more
[Music]
in a spectacular turn of events China
has appointed Hong Kong as the national
center for technology and innovation in
southern China for the first time the
Chinese government has begun financing
research projects in Hong Kong's
universities they've demanded the
government's enforce a doubling of
research and development budgets and
have approved a program to attract
scientists and technologists from all
over the world
but well why we're trying to do this
well folks because Hong Kong has a huge
advantage over the rest of the Asian
continent it's considered a market
economy and it isn't subject to import
restrictions that is Hong Kong companies
can buy whatever they want including
high-tech goods that can have both
civilian and military applications these
are products that the government's and
Chinese companies cannot buy in other
words China wants to take advantage of
Hong Kong's status in order to boost its
technological development plans if it
succeeds that'll be great for China in
Hong Kong but even if that plan is
thwarted China will still get the other
hands with Hong Kong consider this if
the United States and the rest of the
other Western powers imposed
restrictions on Hong Kong and in their
Freeport status this will push the city
even more into China's hands who will be
happy to invest billions in this
territory in exchange for full control
Smart is real smart China
[Music]
anyway folks now you can probably see
it's hard to predict whether we're
facing Hong Kong's decline or whether
we're facing its rebirth but what does
seem clear is that Hong Kong will become
more and more Chinese but now it's your
turn do you think Hong Kong will see a
return to its glory days let us know in
this survey as well as in the comments
below and I really hope you enjoyed this
video please do hit like if you did
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos also please don't forget to check
out our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode the were not mine
also this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]